GOES HIKING ON AN ANT,
DANA PERINO, "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT BIDEN TRYING TO HAVE
IT BOTH WAYS ON RECORD HIGH GAS
PRICES.
WHEN PRICES RISE IT IS THE FAULT
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN, RACIST
REPUBLICANS AND GREEDY OIL
COMPANIES.
SPEAK IT AS AN IMPEDIMENT TO
PRODUCTION IN THE UNITED STATES
AND IT IS CALLED THE BANKERS ON
WALL STREET.
>> PUTIN'S WORDS ARE HURTING
AMERICANS AT THE GAS PUMP.
>> PUTIN GAS HIKE.
>> OF THE CONSEQUENCES OF
PUTIN'S PRICE HIKE.
>> THE REPUBLICANS HAVE LOBBIED
PLENTY OF BLAME BUT HAVE NOT
OFFERED A SINGLE SOLUTION.
>> Greg: IT AS A RESULT OF HIS
GENIUS MASTERMIND
PROBLEM-SOLVING ABILITIES.
THE WHITE HOUSE CALLED OUT FOR
TAKING A VICTORY LAP ON THE
50-CENT DROP IN GAS PRICES EVEN
THOUGH THEY ARE STILL AT RECORD
LEVELS.
>> WE'VE SEEN GAS PRICES GO DOWN
THE LAST 34 STRAIGHT DAYS.
>> -- A GALLON HIGHER THAN WHEN
YOU TOOK OFFICE THOUGH.
>> FIRST OF ALL WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT HOW WE GOT THERE.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE WAR THAT
RUSSIA HAS TAKEN ON IN UKRAINE.
HE >> Greg: AT THE BIDEN
OVAL OFFICE THE BUCK APPARENTLY
DOES NOT STOP THERE BUT IF IT
DID, HUNTER WOULD PROBABLY GIVE
IT TO A STRIPPER.
AFTER COMING HOME EMPTY-HANDED
WITH NO OIL DEAL FROM THE
SAUDIS, BIDEN IS GOING ALL IN ON
GREEN ENERGY.
THEY SAY THAT BIDEN WILL TAKE
ADDITIONAL CLIMATE ACTION AND
MAYOR PETE IS PUSHING ELECTRIC
CARS ON STRUGGLING AMERICANS.
>> IS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ACTIVELY PURSUING HIGH ENERGY
PRICES IN ORDER TO FORCE
AMERICANS INTO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
THE MORE PAIN WE ARE ALL
EXPERIENCING FROM THE
HIGH-PRICED OF GAS THE MORE
BENEFIT THERE IS FOR THOSE WHO
CAN ACCESS ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
>> Greg: WOW, IS THAT FOR
REAL?
THE MORE PAIN?
WE CUT IT OFF BEFORE HE SAID, I
WOULD NEVER SAY THAT.
LIKE THAT ISN'T AMAZING.
>> Dana: THE CLIMATE GUY WHO
WAS ON MILK A BIT OF THIS
AFTERNOON
, I WASN'T ABLE TO HEAR ALL OF
IT BECAUSE I HAD TO GET MY HAIR
DONE, BUT EARLIER HE SAID WE
HAVE TO SPEED THE TRANSITION.
IT'S AS IF THE ADMINISTRATION
KNOWS WHAT THEY WANT TO SAY BUT
THEY CAN'T HELP THEMSELVES
BECAUSE WHAT THEY REALLY WANT TO
DO IS TO TAKE THROUGH THIS
TRANSITION WHICH WOULD BE GREAT
IF IT WAS PHYSICALLY POSSIBLE
BUT IT IS NOT.
THE OTHER THING THAT IS VERY
STRANGE, IT'S LIKE EVERY
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL IS
AUDITIONING FOR THEIR FUTURE JOB
AS A CAR SALESMAN FOR THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE INDUSTRY.
TODAY, YOU HAD ANOTHER INSTANCE
OF THIS AND ALSO I BELIEVE
TOMORROW THE REASON THEY ARE
DOING ALL THIS PRESS TODAY IS
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
DECLARE AN EMERGENCY ON CLIMATE
CHANGE AND DECLARING EMERGENCY
LAST WEEK ON ABORTION CARE AND
DECLARING EMERGENCIES ABOUT
INFLATION -- THEY DON'T EVEN
CARE ABOUT INFLATION.
BUT THE EMERGENCY DECLARATION IS
THE WAY THEY ARE AVOIDING ANY
SORT OF LEADERSHIP
RESPONSIBILITY OR LEGISLATION.
>> Greg: JESSE, THERE ARE SO
MANY EMERGENCIES, WHILE HE IS
PRESIDENT.
I MEAN, WOULDN'T YOU NOT WANT TO
KEEP SAYING THERE'S A LOT OF
EMERGENCIES?
>> Jesse: THERE IS NO
EMERGENCY, IT IS A POLITICAL
EMERGENCY.
IF IT WAS REAL JOE WOULD'VE PUT
SOLAR PANELS ON BOTH OF HIS
HOMES IN DELAWARE.
YOU KNOW THAT DELAWARE DOESN'T
HAVE A SINGLE OFFSHORE TURBINE?
AND JOE HAS BEEN RUNNING
DELAWARE FOR FOR TWO DECADES.
DELAWARE GETS 92% OF ALL OF ITS
ENERGY FOR NATURAL GAS.
ISN'T THAT BEAUTIFUL?
THE GUY DOESN'T EVEN OWN AN
ELECTRIC CAR.
I'M A LITTLE WORRIED THEY ARE
TRYING TO PUT WIND TURBINES OFF
OF THE COAST OF THE
JERSEY SHORE.
I DID A DEEP DIVE INTO IT.
IT'S A DUTCH COMPANY, SO
AMERICANS AREN'T EVEN GOING TO
GET PAID FOR IT.
ENERGY PRICES ARE ACTUALLY GOING
TO GO UP AFTER THEY INSTALL IT.
THE FISHERMEN ARE VERY UPSET
BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO DESTROY
THEIR FISHING WATERS.
AND YOU CAN SEE IT FROM THE
COAST IS WHAT IS GOING TO RUIN
PEOPLE'S VIEW.
I'M GOING TO HAVE TO STAGE A
PROTEST.
I MIGHT CHAIN MYSELF TO WIND
TURBINE, HUNGER STRIKE, I
HAVEN'T DECIDED.
I'M GOING TO TALK TO MY OIL GUY.
DO YOU HAVE AN OIL GUY?
>> Greg: YES, I DO.
>> Jesse: WIRE THE PRICES AT
THE PUMP GOING DOWN?
HE SAID THERE ARE THREE REASONS,
ONE, AMERICAN OIL COMPANIES ARE
AT FULL THROTTLE.
NUMBER TWO, IT ALWAYS GOES DOWN
AFTER JULY 4TH WEEKEND.
AND ALSO FEARS OF A RECESSION.
BUT THEY ARE PREDICTING OIL
PRICES ARE GOING BACK UP.
SO JOE SHOULD NOT BE PATTING
HIMSELF ON THE BACK.
IF THEY SEE BIG EARNINGS COMING
OUT THE NEXT FEW WEEKS OR
HURRICANE HIT THE GULF, THAT IS
GOING TO SEND PRICES SKY-HIGH
AGAIN.
>> Dana: AND THEY ARE GOING TO
BLAME HASHTAG JESSE'S OIL GUY.
>> Greg: THE OIL GUY PRICE
HIKE.
I THINK YOU SHOULD GO FOR A
HUNGER STRIKE BECAUSE YOU'RE
GETTING A LITTLE PUDGY.
THE SURGERY, YOU KIND OF LET YO.
>> Jesse: DO I REALLY?
>> Greg: GERALDO, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THIS TURNAROUND?
IT IS THEIR FAULT WHEN IT IS BAD
AND IT'S MY CREDIT WHEN IT'S
GOOD.
>> Geraldo: I WOULD LIKE TO
FLIP THAT AROUND BECAUSE IF YOU
GET THE BLAME WHEN THE PRICE
GOES UP YOU SHOULD GET THE
CREDIT WHEN THE PRICE GOES DOWN,
THAT SEEMS LOGICAL.
WHAT IS ILLOGICAL IS THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE NOT
LEADING BY EXAMPLE.
ELECTRIC VEHICLES, FOR EXAMPLE.
WHY AREN'T THEY BUYING ALL
ELECTRONIC VEHICLES FOR THE
POST OFFICE?
>> Dana: I THINK THEY ARE.
>> Greg: THEY ARE.
BUSES.
>> Geraldo: THEY DO PILOT
PROJECTS.
JUST DO IT.
FROM NOW ON, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ONLY BUYS ELECTRIC
VEHICLES.
>> Dana: BUT IF THEY ARE SO
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE THAN OTHER
CAR SHOULD THE TAXPAYERS PAY FOR
THAT?
>> Geraldo: I SUBMIT
RESPECTFULLY THAT IF THEY WANT
TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE THAN THEY
HAVE TO BITE THE BULLET.
>> Judge Jeanine: HERE'S WHAT
I THINK I'M A WHEN JOE BIDEN
CAME OUT AND TOLD THE MOM AND
POP GAS STATIONS TO LOWER THE
PRICES, THEY ALL GOT SCARED OF
JOE AND THOUGHT WE BETTER OVER
THE PRICE OF GAS.
THAT IS ALL HOGWASH.
WHAT THIS GUY IS DOING NOW IS
TAKING CREDIT FOR SOMETHING HE
DIDN'T DO.
AND NOW HE DECLARES THIS
EMERGENCY, EVERYBODY'S GOING TO
SAY OH, MY GOSH, WHAT ARE WE
GOING TO DO, THERE'S NOT GOING
TO BE ANY GAS EVEN THOUGH HE IS
TAKING CREDIT FOR MORE GAS,
THEY'VE NOW GOT TO BUY AN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE AND THE AVERAGE
ONE COSTS $64,000.
THE AVERAGE CAR COST $46,000.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN DOESN'T
HAVE A NEW CAR.
SO THE AVERAGE AMERICAN, AND
WHEN PETE BUTTIGIEG SAYS, YOU
MAY PAY A LITTLE MORE ON YOUR
CAR PAYMENT, THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN DOESN'T HAVE A CAR
PAYMENT.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN IS DRIVING
A CAR THAT HE OR SHE HAS HAD FOR
A LONG TIME AND THEY ARE NOT
MAKING PAYMENTS.
THE CAR IS PAID FOR, IT'S OLD,
THEY ARE JUST SURVIVING IN
DECIDING IF THEY HAVE ENOUGH GAS
TO GO TO WORK AND THE SAD PART
OF ALL OF THIS IS THAT THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND AMERICA.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
GOING ON IN AMERICA.
JUST BUY AND ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR
THE GOVERNMENT SHOULD GET
ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
WE DON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO TELL YOU
WHO IT IS BUT THE GUY THAT I BUY
SOME OF MY CAR IS FROM HE SAYS
TO ME, I AM BUYING ONE, I DON'T
EVEN LIKE IT.
I DON'T WANT TO DRIVE IT.
I CAN'T DRIVE IT ANYWHERE BUT
AROUND TOWN.
LET ME FINISH.
THIS IS ALL MAKE-BELIEVE
NONSENSE WHERE AMERICA IS NOT
SUPPORTING THESE GREEN LUNATICS!
>> Geraldo: I WAS DRIVING INTO
WORK TODAY, STARBUCKS, CHARGING
STATIONS IN THE STARBUCKS.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS GROWING.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT IF YOU
ARE AN AMERICAN LIVING IN MIDDLE
AMERICA?
>> Geraldo: I WAS IN MIDDLE
AMERICA APPEARED >> Judge
Jeanine: WHO CARES WHAT IS
GOING ON IN NEW YORK CITY WITH
THE
STARBUCKS?
CLEVELAND!
>> Jesse: HAVE TO STOP EVERY
100 MILES.
>> Judge Jeanine: THANK YOU!
NOW I REST MY CASE!
>> Greg: WHAT IF PEOPLE NEED
GAS AND OIL FOR DIFFERENT
THINGS.
>> Dana: ATTRACTOR?
WHAT HAS HAPPENED, WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN SCIENCE THAT WOULD
MAKE YOU NEED TO DECLARE AN
EMERGENCY.
IT'S NOT LIKE SOMETHING HAS
CHANGED, THE COVID RESTRICTIONS
INITIALLY, THAT WASN'T AN
EMERGENCY BECAUSE YOU NEEDED
THAT.
RIGHT NOW IT IS NOT AN EMERGENCY
ON COVID OR ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT'S A
POLITICAL EMERGENCY.
IT WILL GET US OFF OF THE --
>> Dana: BUT YOU ARE